Kelly is in August of Georgia hi Kelly
how are you I am wonderful it is such an
honor to speak to you thank you for
changing my life for the better well you
changed it I just showed you how how can
I help okay so my parents are the most
amazing parents in the universe and I
would do absolutely anything for them
they completely changed our family tree
for my brother and myself unfortunately
it was not really by example it was more
don't do this we'll never let you do
that you know try to dig your way out so
last year I did my own Total Money
Makeover and I am debt free except for
my house 28 single no kids the story
about my parents my dad went back to
school when he was about 40 currently my
parents are both about 56 my dad went
back to chiropractic school chasing his
dreams and what we thought was going to
be a better income so they are
struggling to get ahead I guess my mom
is part of a corporate layoff and
they're just hurting financially and I'm
wondering if I pay off my mortgage and
then try to help them they'll be 60
which I feel is getting to be too late
to catch up on retirement now morning
should I pause my snowball to help them
tackle their student loans so they can
concentrate on their retirement no no no
it's a sweet sentiment that you have but
they're going to muddle through I mean I
might pay for them to go through
Financial Peace University I might
continue to encourage them by showing
your progress and your life but the best
thing you got to remember is this only
the strong can help the weak mm-hmm
these people are all griping about rich
people and all this stuff that they
forget that that rich people feed more
poor people than poor people feed yeah
and so in your situation I want you to
become financially strong and then
you'll be able to help others including
your parents and that may be that you
help them at retirement because you're
in really really good shape financially
and you can there's a lot of different
things you're facing with that but a lot
of possibilities but
no I think your dad gets his copper
acting business he got has he gotten out
is he in business he's in business the
bigger issues that my mother's always
kind of been the breadwinner of the
family that she was part of a big
corporate layoff last year she's doing
you know her own entrepreneur startup
business but it's just not bringing in
the income that their life was built
around yeah well maybe they need to
rebuild their life yeah as far as
selling a home something along those
lines
yeah okay we don't have a job with to
startup businesses he's actually an
associate with a established practice
she is stable it's it's her so what's he
making and I would guess 60 yeah and
he's got $100,000 in student loan debt
problem mm-hmm
and she used to make how much um I don't
know for sure but I would say about 80
range from what I've okay
picked up yeah and now she's making
twenty or thirty because she's starting
something no I need to adjust their
lifestyle to fit their income okay and
so you think that I should you know just
enroll them in FPU and hope that they
grab hold of it like I did and you dig
Iselle intense
okay so pay off my own mortgage you
think that I will be clear enough to be
able to help them through retirement
after that we listen you can't help the
federal government because it's too
stupid and if your parents continue on
the track they're doing their there's
nobody can help because it's a black
hole for money but if they can turn it
around and they need some help you can
help them but if they just go head to
keep going to head over heels into
stupid decisions
there's nobody can help that math okay
unless you go make two million dollars
or something and then maybe you could
bail them out but I mean people can do
stupid faster than you and I put
together can do smart okay so you've got
to get them to adjust their lifestyle to
their current situation so that they can
begin to make progress on their own but
you know if she can get her business
going and he can build his practice up
you know they could be making more money
than they've ever made in their lives
possibly mm-hmm and that's what we're
holding on for but it's just in this
struggle in the meantime I said well
this biggest struggle in the meantime is
that
not a just--all thing so I wanted to
repay them the only way that I knew how
yeah but but it's not the that their
struggle is not worthy of repayment
because they have not adjusted their
lifestyle is why they have a struggle
okay you know the income they've become
accustomed to was the phrase that sprung
me to life in this conversation and you
know I don't give a crap what income you
became accustomed to you keep your
lifestyle within it whatever it is up
down sideways you know and they have
they just keep going on like nothing's
happened here and you know we're in a
difficult time in a transition time and
it could be that this is the just before
the best time they've ever had but it
won't be if they just keep muddling
along so yeah I'd get them an FPU
and it's a sweet sentiment to want to do
nice things for them it sounds like
they're nice people and I don't mind you
helping them but but let's really help
them and I you know you participating
and allowing them to keep their
lifestyle where it is now and not facing
the realities of their income situation
is not really helping that's just
enabling
you